going over where to find great chinese
cuisine check out las vegas newest
offering the noodle den it's at the las
vegas or at the sahara las vegas uh and
we talk about brand new it's brand new
just opened today just opened today at
11 am very excited so far so good so far
so good the crowd's been great we had
people right at the door coming to
waiting to come in um some locals and
some hotel guests as well i forgot to
introduce you how rude of me
is the director of restaurants for
sahara las vegas thanks for being here
and chef sam's helping us out he's
actually hand making noodles as we speak
correct so he's doing all the hard work
we have the easy work in the house right
we get to serve his amazing food so he's
making the hand pulled noodles which is
really what we um specialize at noodle
den and you can really taste the
difference
it's an art in and of itself right
absolutely so we have a showcase kitchen
which is great similar to our una mas
restaurant as well at sahara las vegas
where you can watch the chefs make the
noodles and just really the excitement
as people walk by and they're making the
noodles that you're about to eat 15
minutes later when you're seated all
right so if they go there what should
they ask for to make sure they get the
handmade the fresh noodles so our
servers are great they kind of walk you
through the menu it's really meant to be
shared you know you can start with dim
sum and then go into hand pulled noodles
so this is our he's making our handful
noodle soup which is one of the dishes
that we brought today yeah you have some
items on display here including dessert
those little pumpkins there absolutely
so we something unique about chef sam
and his team they really want to have
fun with it we want our guests to enjoy
what they're eating visually and
appetite so those are pumpkin desserts
and we also have the swan crisp with a
red bean inside so just something fun uh
instagramable moments and pictures that
we can take yeah and then you said these
look like handbags right exactly so
these are our crab
and shrimp jade purses so it kind of
looks like a purse a woman's purse so
kind of fun and chef want to have a good
time with and enjoy the guests when they
come in presentation is a big part of
the whole thing at the noodle den right
absolutely presentation the atmosphere
of the restaurant our designer did a
really good job designing the restaurant
with feng shui as well so when guests
come in they feel really good and then
obviously the presentation of chef sam
and then the food when you finish it off
chef sam's very close to being done
there right absolutely absolutely so
this is the finished product
chef sam is making noodles for years now
and we're just really excited to be on
property how long does someone have to
train to do that uh
one year yeah so about a year but chef's
been doing it for multiple years since
china so derek if we if we ask you to do
that right now it wouldn't go well oh it
would it would probably look like this
one it would not look anything beautiful
like chef said me too as well we'll
leave that to the bag of house
professionals so the noodle den is brand
new what else is going on as far as
restaurants at the sahara so we have
bala coming up as well next year cheeks
and peach just opened so it's been doing
really well and then obviously our
staple which is bizarre steakhouse by
jose andreas well congratulations on the
new opening and everything you're doing
well there at the sahara it's the noodle
den at sahara las vegas derek chef sam
thanks for joining us